♪ ♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE.
THEY TAKE STARRING ROLE IN A
CAN'T-MISS SEEING AN UNSEEN.
BUT FIRST, JOE BIDEN TRIES TO
FEEL HER PAIN.
A WHITE HOUSE FRESH OUT OF IDEAS
IS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO SAY
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS.
THE MATTER HOW MUCH THEY'VE
TINKERED WITH THEIR MESSAGING WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS, AMERICANS ARE
JUST NOT BUYING WHAT THEY'RE
SELLING.
NOW THE PRESS IS ACTUALLY DOING
DIRE ASSESSMENTS.
HE IS AT OR NEAR AT HIS LOW END
OF A JOB APPROVAL DURING HIS
TERM.
IN CNN'S LATEST POLL OF POLLS IS
OBLITERATING AT JUST 39%.
NOW PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF GOODWILL LEFT FOR
THE PUBLIC THIS WEEK.
BUT THE CONFLICTING MESSAGES
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE BROADER
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE THERE IS NO PLAN TO TURN
THINGS AROUND ENDED ADVANCE OF
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS WHICH ARE
JUST OVER 200 DAYS OFF.
GIVEN THAT THE DEMOCRATS DECIDED
TO CHANGE THE POLICY ON ENERGY
AND BORDERS THAT MAKE IT SO
UNPOPULAR, WHAT CAN JOE BIDEN
DO?
WELL, HE CAN PRETEND THAT HE
FEELS YOUR PAIN.
BECAUSE HE WAS POOR TOO WANTS.
>> I GREW UP IN A HOUSEHOLD THAT
WE LIVED IN A SPLIT LEVEL HOME,
THREE BEDROOMS, FOUR KIDS, MOM
AND DAD AND GRANDPARENTS.
I WAS OF THE GREAT PLEASURE OF
BEING IN LISTON AND CONGRESS.
I'LL STILL MAKE AN ACTIVE A LOT
MORE MONEY BECAUSE I WAS GETTING
A CENTER SALARY.
NO KIDDING.
I DIDN'T THINK YOU SHOULD MAKE
MONEY WHILE YOU'RE IN OFFICE.
>> Laura: TO DRIVE HOME THE
POVERTY POINT, HE FOLLOWED UP
WITH AN EARLY-MORNING TWEET
TODAY SAYING.
I KNOW THAT FAMILIES ARE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH HIGHER PRICES, I
GREW UP IN A FAMILY WHERE THE
PRICE OF GAS WENT UP, WE FELT
IT.
NOW LET ME UNDERSTAND THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE BELIEVES THAT
THE FAMILIES WHO ARE GETTING
ERODED BY INFLATION, THEY'RE
SAYING THE NEIGHBORHOODS GO
THROUGH VIOLENT CRIMES OR TO
FEEL BETTER NOW?
BECAUSE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
CLAIMED EMPATHY THAT CARRIED
OVER FROM EXPERIENCES SEVERAL
DECADES AGO?
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HAS LIVED ON
THE HILL FOR YEARS NOW WE KNOW
THAT.
A MEMBER JUST LAST WEEK WE
LEARNED THAT ACCORDING TO THE
TEXT FROM HUNTER'S OLD LAPTOP
THAT HIS SON WAS COVERING
EXPENSES FOR THE FAMILY.
WHEN JANUARY 2019 TEXT OF THE
SISTERS SAYING HOPE YOU ALL CAN
DO WHAT I DID AND PAY FOR
EVERYTHING FOR THIS ENTIRE
FAMILY FOR 30 YEARS.
30 YEARS.
IT'S REALLY HARD BUT DON'T
WORRY, UNLIKE POP I WON'T LET
YOU GIVE ME HALF YOUR SALARY.
30 YEARS, THREE DECADES.
THAT WOULD COVER A SIGNIFICANT
STRETCH OF HIS SENATE CAREER.
WHEN HE WAS THE POOREST MEMBER.
THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD REMIND
YOU THAT THROUGHOUT THE
CAMPAIGN, JOE BIDEN GROUSED AT
ANY AND PROPRIETARY AS IT
RELATED TO HUNTER.
>> HOW MANY TIMES.
>> I'VE NEVER SPOKEN TO MY SON.
I'VE NEVER DISCUSSED WITH MY SON
MY BROTHER OR ANYONE ELSE HAVE
ANY TWO OF THEIR BUSINESSES.
>> WHAT'S YOUR UNDERSTANDING
WHAT YOUR SON WAS DOING FOR AN
EXTRA ORDINARY AMOUNT OF MONEY?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
>> Laura: NOW LOOK, ANYONE
WHO'S HAD SOME SUCCESS AND NOW
HAS GROWN KIDS WE KNOW THAT THEY
WORRY MORE ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN
THAT ABOUT THEMSELVES.
SO HOPING HUNTER IS BY FAR THE
BEST WAY TO INFLUENCE JOE
BECAUSE JOE WORRIES MORE ABOUT
HUNTER THAN HE DOES ABOUT
HIMSELF.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU'RE A
PARENT.
THE FACT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON REFUSED TO ADMIT
THESE OBVIOUS FACTS SHOWS THAT
OUR ESTABLISHMENT BELIEVES IT'S
OKAY FOR POLITICIANS TO USE
THEIR OFFICES TO ENRICH THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT OF COURSE IT ONLY EXTENDS
THE DEMOCRATS.
MEANWHILE, AS PRESENT JOE BIDEN
TALKED ABOUT HIS FOREIGN POLICY
TEAM TONIGHT, HE WANTS YOU TO
THINK THAT HE HAS A MAN FOR ALL
SEASONS.
THAT HE WILL LEAD THE WORLD OUT
OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
BUT UNLESS THAT BEGINS WITH
REDOUBLING OUR EFFORTS TO TAKE
ON CHINA, WHILE THE REST IS ALL
BLUSTER.
AND A MEMBER WHY THEIR INABILITY
TO CONFRONT CHINA IS SO
SIGNIFICANT AS IT RELATES TO THE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN SCHEME.
IT DOCUMENTS UNVEILED TWO MONTHS
AGO SHOW THAT HUNTER AND JOE'S
BROTHER JIM RECEIVED MONTHLY
PAYMENTS OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND $65,000 RESPECTIVELY
AS PART IS IN AUGUST 2017
CONSULTING AGREEMENT BETWEEN
HUNTER, A TOP OFFICIAL AT A CCP
ENERGY COUNTRY.
JIM BY ITS COMPANY RECEIVED
PAYMENTS DIRECTLY FROM A COMPANY
JOINTLY OWNED AT THE TIME BY
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAW FIRM.
THE TAKE AWAY ARE UNDENIABLE.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S FOCUS IS
INCAPABLE OF ANY FOCUS AT ALL IS
ENRICHING HIS FAMILY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE BEFORE HE LEAVES THIS
EARTH.
THIS WILL REQUIRE CHINA AFTER
THE AMERICAN LEFT.
AND SO FAR HE'S DOING BOTH.
PROFITING OFF OF HIS STINT IN
THE SENATE, HIS EIGHT YEARS AS
VICE PRESIDENT, AND EVEN NOW
WHEN HE IS PRESIDENT.
IT IS JUST WHAT THE BIDENS DO.
AND NOW AS THE BIDENS WERE A JOY
THERE WERE WARDS OF THEIR DIRTY
FAMILY INFLUENCE BUSINESS,
AMERICANS THEMSELVES THEY ARE
SUFFERING UNDER JOE BIDEN'S
BUMBLING CARELESS WATCH.
AND I'M TELLING YOU THIS
TONIGHT, NO ATTEMPT AT
PLAYACTING THE ROLE OF AN
EMPATHETIC CHARACTER IS GONNA
MAKE IT FEEL A